so future of storytelling before we do
the future let's talk about what is
never going to change about storytelling
what's never gonna change obviously I
think good stories are never going to
change the need for people to gather
together and exchange their stories and
to talk about the things that feel
universal the idea that we all feel a
compelling need to watch stories to tell
stories to share stories sort of the
gathering around the campfire to discuss
the things that tell each one of us that
we are not alone in the world those
things to me are never gonna change like
that essence of storytelling is never
gonna change okay in preparation for
this conversation I checked in with
Susan line who is running ABC
entertainment when you were working on
Grey's Anatomy yes and she said that
there was this indelible memory she had
of your casting process where without
discussing it with any of the executives
you got people coming in to read for
your scripts and every one of them was
the full range of humanity you did not
type anyone in anyway and that it was
completely surprising
so she said in addition to retraining
the studio executives you also she feels
and I think this is I agree retrained
the expectations of the American TV
audience so what else does the audience
not yet realize that it needs what else
today not yet realized well I mean I
don't think we're anywhere near there
yet I mean we're still in a place in
which you know we're far far behind what
looks like the real world in actuality
like I wasn't bringing in a bunch of
actors who looked very different from
one another simply because I was trying
to make a point and I wasn't trying to
do anything special it never occurred to
me that that was new different or weird
I just brought in actors because I
thought they were interesting and to me
the idea that it was completely
surprising to everybody I didn't know
that for a while
I just
these are the actors I want to see play
these parts I want to see what their
look like if they read we'll see what
happens so I think the the interesting
thing that happens is that when you look
at the world through another lens when
you're not the person normally in charge
of things it just comes out a different
way mm-hmm so you now you have this big
machine that you run as a Titan as you
know last year when she gave her talk
she's a Titan so what do you think is
going to happen as we go on there's a
huge amount of money involved in
producing these shows while the tools of
making stories have gone gotten greatly
democratized there's still this large
distribution you know people who rent
networks who rent the audience to
advertisers and make it all pay how do
you see the the business model changing
now that anyone can be a storyteller
I think it's changing every day I mean
the rapid rapid change that's happening
is amazing and I feel I mean the panic
is palpable and I don't mean that in a
bad way I think it's kind of exciting
the idea that there's sort of an
equalizer happening that sort of means
that anybody can make something is
wonderful I think there's something
scary and the idea that you can't find
the good work now there's so much work
out there I think there's something like
417 dramas on television right now and
at any given time and any given place
but you can't find them you can't find
the good ones so there's a lot of bad
stuff out there because everybody can
make something it's like if everybody
painted a painting you know and not that
many good painters so but finding the
good stories the good shows is harder
and harder and harder because if you
have one tiny show over here on AMC and
one tiny show over here over there
finding where they are becomes much
harder so I think that ferreting out the
gems and finding out who made the great
webisode and who made this it's I mean
think about the poor critics who now are
spending 24 hours a day trapped in their
homes watching everything it's not an
easy job right now so the distribution
engines are getting you know more and
more vast but finding the good
programming for everybody in the
audience it's getting harder
and unlike the news where everything's
getting winnowed down to just who you
are
television seems to beginning and by
television I mean anything you can watch
television on shows on it seems to be
getting wider and wider and wider and so
anybody's making stories and the
geniuses are sometimes hidden but it's
gonna be harder to find and at some
point that will collapse people keep
talking about peak TV I don't know when
that's gonna happen I think at some
point it'll collapse a little bit and
we'll sort of come back together I don't
know if it'll be network television I
don't know if that model is sustainable
mmm-hmm what about the the model that
you know Amazon and Netflix are throwing
it a lot of money around right now that
is true I think it's an interesting
model I mean I think there's something
exciting about it for for content
creators I think there's something
exciting about it for the world I think
there's something exciting about it the
idea that there are programs now that
can be in multiple languages with
characters from all over the world that
are appealing and come out for everybody
at the same time he's exciting mm-hmm I
mean I think the International sense
that television can now take on make
sense to me that programming can now
take on television so much is made for
like here's our American audience we
make these shows and then they shove
them out into the world and hope for the
best as opposed to really thinking about
the fact that America is not it I mean
we love ourselves and everything that
it's not it and it should be taking we
should taking into account the fact that
there are all of these other places in
the world that we should be interested
in while we're telling stories it makes
the world smaller it I don't know it
just I think it pushes forward the idea
that the world is a universal place and
our stories become universal things we
stop being other you've pioneered as far
as I can see interesting ways to launch
new shows too I mean when you launch
scandal in 2012 there was this amazing
groundswell of support on Twitter that
the likes of which nobody had seen
before do you have any any other tricks
up your sleeve when you launch your next
one or what do you think will happen in
we do have some interesting ideas for
four we have a show called still
star-crossed it's going to come out this
summer we have some interesting ideas
for that I'm not sure if we're gonna be
able to do them in time I thought they
were very fun and funny but you know the
idea that we would live tweet our show
was really just us thinking that would
be fun we didn't realize that the
critics would start to live tweet along
with us but the fans you know getting
people to be a part of it making it more
of a campfire you know when you're all
on Twitter together and you're all
talking together it is more of a shared
experience and finding other ways to
make that possible and finding other
ways to make people feel engaged is
important mm-hmm so when you have all
those different people making stories
and only some of them are gonna break
through and get that audience somehow
how how do you think storytellers will
get paid I actually have been struggling
with this concept as well like is it
going to be a subscriber model are
people gonna say like I'm gonna watch
you know this particular person's shows
and that's that's how we're gonna do it
I think we should buy a passport to
shaundalyn
right I don't know about that but yeah
that's a lot more work for me but I do
think that there are gonna be different
ways but I don't know necessarily I mean
a lot of I'll be honest and say a lot of
content creators are not necessarily
interested in being distributors mainly
because what I during them doing is
creating content like I really love to
create content I want to get paid for it
I want to get paid the money that I
deserve to get paid for it and there's a
hard part in finding that but I also
want it to be made possible for you know
my are the people who work with me the
people who work for me everybody to sort
of get paid in a way and they're all
making a living how it gets distributed
is it's getting harder and harder how
about the many new tools you know VR AR
I find it fascinating that you can't you
can't really binge watch you can't fast
forward in those things how what do you
see is the future of those for
storytelling I spent a lot of time in
the past year just exploring those
getting lots of demonstrations and
paying attention I find them fascinating
mainly because I think that I think most
people think of them for gaming
I think most people think of them for
things like action and I think that
there is a sense of intimacy that is
very present in those things the idea
that picture this you can sit there and
have a conversation with Fitz or at
least sit there well Fitz talks to you
president Fitzgerald grant the third
while he talks to you about why he's
making a choice that he makes and it's a
very heartfelt moment and instead of you
watching a television screen you're
sitting there next to him and he's
having this conversation now you fall in
love with a man while he's watching you
know I was doing it from a television
screen imagine sitting next to him or
being with a character like Huck who's
about to execute somebody and instead of
having a scene where you know he's
talking to another character very
rapidly he goes into a closet and turns
to you and tells you you know what's
gonna happen and why he's afraid and
nervous it's a little more like theater
and I'm not sure it would work but I'm
fascinated by the concept of something
like that and what that would mean for
an audience and to get to play with
those ideas would be interesting and I
think for you know my audience the the
you know the people who watch my show
which is you know women 12 to 75 there's
something interesting in there for them
mm-hmm and how about the input of the
audience how interested are you in the
things where the audience can actually
go up to a certain point and then decide
oh wait I'm gonna choose my own
adventure I'm gonna run off with Fitz or
I'm gonna run the choose your adventure
stories I have a hard time with those
and not necessarily because I you know I
want to be in control of everything but
because I when I'm watching television
or I'm watching a movie I know for a
fact that a story is not as good when I
have control over exactly what's going
to happen to somebody else's character
you know if I could tell you exactly
what I wanted to happen to Walter White
that's great but the story is not the
same it's not as powerful you know if
I'm in charge of how the Sopranos ends
then that's lovely and I have an ending
that's nice and satisfying but it's not
the same story and it's not the same
emotional impact I can't
I'm just really I can't stop imagining
with that my baby it's how you're losing
me for wonderful is I don't I don't get
to imagine it because you know they have
their Vince has
ending and it makes it really powerful
to know that somebody else is told you
know if you could decide that you know
in Jaws the shark wins or something it
it doesn't do what it needs to do for
you the story is the story that it's
told and you can walk away angry and you
can walk away debating and you can walk
away arguing but that's why it works
that is why it's art otherwise it's just
a game and games can be art but in a
very different way mm-hmm gamers who
actually sell the right to sit there and
comment on what's happening to me that's
more community than storytelling well
and that is its own form of campfire
like I don't discount that as a form of
storytelling it but it is a there's a
group form I suppose mm-hmm all right
what about the super super the fact that
everything's getting shorter shorter
shorter and you know snapchat now has
something it calls shows that are one
minute long it's interesting part of me
thinks it sounds like commercials I mean
it does like sponsored by but part of me
also gets it completely there's
something really wonderful about it if
you think about a world in which most
people are watching television on their
phones if you think about a place like
India where that's where most of the
input is coming in and that's where most
the product is coming in shorter makes
sense if you can charge people more for
shorter periods of content some
distributors figured out a way to make a
lot more money if you're making content
it costs less money to make it and put
it out there and by the way if you're 14
in short attention span theater like my
daughter that's what you want to see
that's what you want to make that's how
it works and if you do it right and it
actually feels like narrative people
will hang on for it no matter what you
do I'm glad you raised your daughters
because I'm wondering how are they going
to consume entertainment and also not
just entertainment but news too when
they're not I mean the algorithmic robot
overlords are going to feed them what
they've already done how do you think we
will correct for that and make people
well-rounded
well me and how I correct for it is
completely different than how somebody
else might do it I'm free to speculate I
really don't know how we're gonna do it
in the future I mean my poor children
have been the subject of all of my
experiment we're still doing what I call
Amish summers where I turn off all
electronics and pack away all their
computers and stuff and watch them
scream for a while until they settle
down into like an electronic free summer
but honestly it's a very hard world in
which now as grown-ups were so
interested in you know watching our own
thing and we don't even know that we're
being fed sometimes just our own
opinions you know the way the way it's
working now you're watching a feed and
the feeds are being corrected so that
you're only getting your own opinions
and you're feeling more and more right
about yourself so how do you how do you
really start to discern it's getting a
little bit disturbing so maybe it'll
overcorrect maybe it'll all explode or
maybe we'll all just become I hate to be
negative about it but maybe we'll all
just become more idiotic yeah can you
can you picture any corrective that you
could do it's script was scripted with
you know fictional where I think a lot
about the fact that I you know that
television has the power to educate
people in a powerful way and when you're
watching television for instance they do
studies about medical shows 98 II think
it's 87 percent eighty seven percent of
people getting most of their knowledge
about medicine and medical facts from
medical shows much more so than from
their doctors you'd be spending some
articles right so you want to be
accurate so we worked really hard to be
accurate and every time we make a
mistake I feel really guilty like we're
gonna do something bad but we also give
a lot of good medical information there
are so many other ways to give
information on those shows people are
being entertained and maybe you don't
want to read the news but there are a
lot of ways to give fair and unbiased
information out on those shows not in
some like creepy like we're gonna I
don't know control people's minds way
but in a way that's sort of very
interesting and intelligent and not not
about pushing one side's version or the
other like giving out the truth it would
be strange though if television drama
was how we were giving the news it would
be strange but a lot of what
I gather a lot of what you've written as
fiction has become prediction this
season you know scandal has been very
disturbing for that reason and we have
this show that's about politics gone mad
and basically the way we've always told
the show you know everybody pays
attention to the papers we read
everything we talk about everything we
have lots of friends in Washington and
we'd always sort of done our show as a
speculation we'd sit in the room and
think what would happen if the wheels
came off the bus and everything went
crazy and that was always great except
now it felt like the wheels were coming
off the bus and things were actually
going crazy so the things that we were
speculating were really coming true I
mean we had our season this year was
going to end with the Russians
controlling the American election and
then we hadn't I mean we've written it
we'd had planned for it it was all there
and then the Russians were suspected of
being involved in the American election
and we suddenly had to change what we
were gonna do for our season I walked in
and I was like that scene where our
mystery woman starts speaking Russian we
have to fix that and figure out what
we're gonna do that just comes from
extrapolating out you know from what we
thought was gonna happen or what we
thought was crazy
uh-huh that's great so where where else
in the US or elsewhere in the world do
you look who's doing interesting
storytelling right now I don't know
there's a lot of interesting stuff out
there obviously British television is
always amazing and always does
interesting things I don't get to watch
a lot of TV mainly because I'm Canadian
working and I pretty much try not to
watch very much television at all in
American television until I'm done with
the season because things start to creep
into my head otherwise I get sort of I
start to wonder like why can't our
characters wear crowns and talk about
being on a throne it gets crazy
so I try not to watch much until the
seasons are over but I do think that
there's a lot of interesting European
television out there I was at the
international Emmys and looking around
and seeing this the stuff that they were
showing and I was kind of fascinated
there's some stuff I want to watch and
check out can you imagine I know that
you don't like spend a lot of time
thinking about tech stuff but is there
can you you know how a few years ago we
had someone here at Ted talking about
seeing
you know wearing Google glass and seeing
your TV shows essentially in your eye
and can you do you ever fantasize when
you know the little girl is sat on the
pantry floor in your parents house did
you ever imagine any other medium or
would you now any other medium for
storytelling other than books I mean I I
grew up on TV Toni Morrison so no that
didn't even imagine televisions so the
idea that there could be some bigger
world some more magical way of making
things I'm always excited when new
technology comes out and I'm always the
first one to want to try it the
possibilities feel and listen exciting
right now which is what excites me we're
in this sort of Wild West period to me
it feels like because nobody knows what
we're gonna settle on you can put
stories anywhere right now
and that's cool to me and it feels like
once we figure out how to get the
technology and the creativity of the
storytelling to meet the possibilities
are endless and also the technology has
enabled the thing I briefly flew by
earlier binge-viewing which is a recent
phenomenon since you've been doing shows
right and how do you think does that
change the storytelling process at all
like you always had a Bible for the
whole season beforehand right no I just
always know where we're going to end so
for me the only way I can really comment
on that is that I have a show that's
been going on for 14 seasons and so
there are the people have been watching
it for 14 seasons and then there are the
12 year old girls I did encounter in the
grocery store who've watched 297
episodes in three weeks seriously and
it's a very different experience for
them because they've been inside of
something really intensely for a very
long period of time you know for a very
short period of time in a very intense
way and in them the story has a
completely different arc and a
completely different meaning because it
never had any breaks it's like visiting
a country and then leaving it
it's a straining and amazing novel mhm
and then putting it down I mean I think
that is the beauty of the experience you
don't necessarily have to watch
something for 14 seasons
it's not necessarily the way
everything's supposed to be is there any
topic that you don't think we should
touch I I don't think I think of story
that way and I think of story in terms
of character and what characters were
doing what characters need to do in
order to make them move forward so I'm
never really thinking of story in terms
of just plot and when writers come into
my writers room and pitch me plot I say
you're not speaking English like that's
the thing I say we're not speaking
English I need to hear what's what's
real and so I don't think of it that way
I don't know if there's a way to think
like there's something I wouldn't do
because that feels like I'm plucking
pieces of plot off a wall or something
no that's great to what extent do you
think you will use you know you recently
went on the board of Planned Parenthood
and got involved in the Hillary Clinton
campaign to what extent do you think you
will use your storytelling in the real
world to affect change well you know
there's that's an intense subject to me
because I feel like their lack of
narratives that a lot of that a lot of
people have is is difficult you know
like there's there's a lot of
organizations that don't have a positive
a positive narrative that they created
for themselves that would help them
there's a lot of campaigns that could it
could help be helps with a better
narrative we could the Democrats could
do a lot with a with a very strong
narrative for themselves there's a lot
of different things that can happen in
terms of using storytelling voice and I
don't mean that in a fiction way I mean
that in the same way that you know any
speech writer wouldn't mean it and I I
see that but I don't necessarily know
that that's like my job to do that all
right please help me thank Shonda thank
you